I got a question for you you've done two
of the Comedy Central Roast now correct
and how does the roast battle differ
from the actual roast to you I'm dying
to roast battle by the way the Comedy
Central execs that I want to do it I
don't know if he'll be down to do it
because I don't I don't know that he
wants to do that kind of thing but I was
watching Jeff do it I was like I'm so
jealous
I want to write jokes I wanted I want to
prove that I deserve to be on the
judge's table for this show so I'm I'm
not saying I do want to come back as a
judge of the show continues which I
believe it will why wouldn't it but I
want to give up one of the episodes that
I judge to rose-petal I would gladly do
it and I would love to do it I think um
the the way it differed for me it was
that I wanted in on it a little bit more
I wanted and as a judge I didn't feel
comfortable going as hard as I as the
jokes in my head for certain people
because I don't know you personally and
that's not my job as a judge is to like
get in these amazing one-liner jokes
it's a it's about couching your jokes
with judgment and I wanted to just write
roast jokes and have jokes for you guys
so so that was that was the difference
for me was that I was like when you were
our resident female perspective on this
show you know that is it's there's so
much testosterone I guess on this show
right you know I guess they say commies
kind of a boys club in a sense and now
what we've learned over doing this for
five years that uh women are the best
roast battlers I mean like they're so
hearts the specific they're so efficient
I mean they're just so nasty they really
murdered their opponents tops last
girlfriend broke up with him and I don't
blame her because every time he went
down on her he would tap out after a
three-count
Joe has OCD which is weird because his
dick is a mess really sweet I'm so proud
of the women that I saw through this and
I'm it's you guys didn't put women in to
be nice to feel some sort of quota you
didn't but you don't have to exactly
that's what I always tell people who are
like you know well we gotta have a girl
do this or we got we have the one girl
and I go put in two because we're
good we've had to fight hard to
get good Olivia is dating a man for the
same reason she gives herself awful
haircuts she's bad at scissoring Jamar's
you look like your dad said Beetlejuice
three times before he came
it's such a big pool of just great I
mean it's battles and gentlemen yeah
they just happen to be women and these
strong women that it's it sucks being a
woman and having your looks made fun of
because you're already judged so harshly
for your looks not that men aren't in
this business because they are but for
these young women for Nicole who's 22
right to get out there and be called all
the things she was called and stand up
there and just take it and just have
these great one-liners back the cow
wanted to go to law school but she
settled for having a face that looks
like it was hit with the bar Joe I don't
get it if you don't think I'm hot why
are you drooling like inspired by her
and threatened but you know just really
inspired by the female talent coming out
and I wish roast battle would have been
around when I was a young comic cuz I
would have I needed that sort of
community that I think you guys have
made it a comfortable place for women
and I really appreciate hearing them it
really is I don't feel any I don't feel
like it's a mask I when you said that
I'm like I know I disagree I feel like
it is a place it's a really feminist
environment I feel like all the men on
there aside from like Jamar are probably
feminine I think every female one except
for Olivia who's androgynous anyway so
yeah it's everyone I you guys just treat
us like equals and it's not like our
female jutted like oh you had me cuz you
probably needed a woman up there you
know you were going to have one
regardless but I didn't feel like I was
there because I was a woman I felt like
I was there because I was funny and I
think all the women on there felt that
nothing but killers yeah yeah
[Applause]